How long do I continue to take the folio path for radiation by PET skin?
What else detoxens the radiation radioactive glucose tracer?
So, I suggest you take that folio path for radiation to just finish them on.
Because getting radiation and radioactive elements out of your body is a lifelong process.
Other things that can help pull out radiation and things are just other key layers.
The biggest thing that's going to pull out any toxins from your body are going to be just supporting your liver phase 1, 2, 3.
So, go back to the phases of detoxification information.
You could even go to the 7 phases of detox course and understand the phase 1, 2, 3 of your liver.
Make sure you're having good molecules.
I know the person that asked this, still having trouble trying to get those under control.
If you're not really supporting those 7 phases of detox, well, you're not going to get anything out of the tissues.
Because if it does get into the bloodstream and it circulates, and it can't get through the liver because the liver is too crowded, then it's just going to be deposited somewhere else in the body.
And it even if it does get pulled out in there through chelation and it dumped back into the one through the limb system circulates around, if the liver is too crowded, it's going to circulate again, and it's going to be down somewhere else.
So, you know, supporting all the phases of detoxification is really the key to detoxifying anything.
So, just go back to that 7 phases of detox and make sure that you start at phase 6 and go backwards.